es gibt zu unserem thema heute einen
statistischen index es ist der
sogenannte transformations- index und
der gibt wissenschaftlich fundiert das
verhältnis zwischen demokratisch und
autoritär regierten staaten an für 2022
weiß dieser index nun erstmals etwas 20
jahren wieder mehr autokratien als
demokratin aus sind nämlich 67
demokratien und 70 autokratien die
hoffnung also irgendwann könnte die welt
tatsächlich zu einem ende der geschichte
kommen in dem alle staaten dieser welt
demokratisch sein diese hoffnung hat
sich stand jetzt als trugschluss
erwiesen wir wollen reden heute über das
verhältnis von demokratien und
autokratien und arbeit begrüße ich sie
sehr herzlich zu einem neuen forum
demokratie
und ich freue mich über meine gäste ich
begrüße sehr herzlich marieluise beck
die gründerin des zentrum für liberale
moderne ich begrüße sehr herzlich
norbert röttgen außenpolitische experte
der cdu csu fraktion im deutschen
bundestag
ich begrüße sehr herzlich professor
harald welzer sozialpsychologe und
soziologe und begrüße sehr herzlich
professor manfred görtemaker historiker
an der universität potsdam und sie
begleiten uns schon sehr lange in form
demokratie herzlich willkommen an sie
alle er hat wo man diese tage hin hört
hört man staatspräsidenten
regierungschefinnen vor der kamera die
die oft sagen so was wie wir werden
gewinnen oftmals ist da das gewinnen der
demokratie gegenüber autokratien gemeint
befinden wir uns wieder mitten in einem
systemkonflikt im krieg der systeme
wenn sie das wieder streichen würde ich
sagen ja wir sind in einem
systemkonflikt das
wiederbeleben frage stellen weil es eine
andeutung vielleicht mit sich trägt es
ist so etwas wie es ist etwas da was
schon mal da war nämlich der kalte krieg
und es ist in nicht die wiederholung des
kalten krieges es ist eine ganz neue
system rivalität die die geopolitik da
die beziehungen der staaten miteinander
prägt und ich glaube der große konflikt
ist geht aus von vor allen dingen von
china auch von russland nicht nur weil
sie autokratien und diktatoren übrigens
inzwischen sind sondern sie verbindet
der revisionismus beide wollen die
ordnung verändern putin will hat sich
nie abgefunden mit dem ergebnis des
kalten krieges er akzeptiert wird die
europäische friedensordnung und
politische ordnung neu schreiben und
chipping dass china unterschiedlich
empfing will die internationale norden
die globale ordnung die sich nach dem
ende des zweiten weltkrieges entwickelt
hat die wir die liberale regel
gegründete ordnung nennen ersetzen
erhält diese ordnung für den ausdruck
westlicher werte und des amerikanischen
machtanspruchs und er findet es nicht
mehr in ordnung dass der heute gilt er
will das prinzip des rechts durch das
prinzip der macht ersetzen und das ist
fundamental es geht also um die
herausforderung der ordnung der
ordnungen durch vor allen dingen china
aber hier bei uns auch durch russland
das und das macht den geopolitischen
konflikt aus vor allen dingen weil durch
den chinesischen machtanspruch der
westen vor allen dingen die usa sich in
allem herausgefordert fühlen
technologisch ökonomisch militärisch
geopolitisch und das glaube ich
kennzeichnet und wird kennzeichen noch
für eine lange zeit die internationalen
beziehungen
frau beck wenn wir noch ein bisschen
näher bei russland bleiben bevor wir
später dann auch zur china kommen man
hat ja so ein bisschen den eindruck dass
man durch den puschen angriffskrieg auch
ein stückweit aufgewacht ist dass wir
zum automatismus zurückgekehrt sind aber
ist es nicht ist das nicht auch ein
stück weit ein trugschluss ist es nicht
schon viel früher so gewesen dass wir
mit russland eine autokratie und eine
diskothek erkennen konnten ja das würde
ich bestätigen
vielleicht kann ich nochmal anknüpfen an
roth können dieses zentrum liberale
moderne ist ja von uns vor fünf jahren
aus der taufe gehoben worden
genau weil wir diese entwicklung gesehen
haben weil wir gesehen haben und das war
vor diesem krieg der krieg in der
ukraine geht ja schon seit acht jahren
als war aber weil eigentlich erkennbar
war dass wir in ein neues zeitalter
hineinlaufen mit rapiden veränderungen
einer hohen
dramatik der technologische erfindungen
der künstlichen intelligenz die alles
auf den kopf stellen was wir bisher an
veränderungen des lebensalltags erlebt
haben und das ist dafür vielleicht
sogar durch die autoritären systeme und
dafür steht china
überzeugenderen wege gibt mit diesen
rapiden entwicklungen umzugehen
als wir mit unseren liberalen offenen
systemen also das ist die offene frage
die offene wette
und deswegen
liberale moderne also moderne in die wir
hineingeboren
das erleben wir jetzt wie werden wenn
wir über energieversorgung moderne form
der in der energieversorgung sprechen
aber eben dann auch in der frage gelingt
es uns die offenen gesellschaften zu
erhalten oder werden wir alle durch
diese technologien und durch diese
entwicklung in
autokratische bis totalitäre entwicklung
hineingehen zu russland ja ich glaube
die entscheidende frage ist mit wem hat
man in russland gesprochen
ich habe immer mit einem gewissen sorge
gesehen dass er
allein nach moskau gefahren ist und dort
die schicken lokale und der herr mess
und anderen beschäftige sehen hat der
musste den eindruck bekommen das ist
doch ein modernes land hier ist alles in
ordnung
wer und das war eben im wesentlichen
meine partner wer mit den
nichtregierungsorganisationen
mit den menschenrechts organisationen
mit den anwälten die versucht haben
demokratische freiheiten zu vertreten
wir mit denen kontakt hatte der wusste
eigentlich schon mit 2000 2001 dass das
system putin
bedeutet eine
systematisch
zunächst mal engführung aber eine
systematische
aufbau von hierarchie mit abbau von
demokratischen rechten und mit einer
grossen
zerstörerischen bereitschaft was wir
ausgeblendet haben nämlich kosten es ist
tschetschenien und die stadt grosny dem
erdboden gleichgemacht worden mit
unglaublichen menschenopfern und das war
zu beginn der regierungszeit von
proteinen also wir hätten ist lange
sehen können wir wollten es nicht sehen
der welser da würde ich gerne eingreifen
hat putin tatsächlich die vielzitierten
westlichen werte und die liberalität bei
uns schon vor langer zeit angegriffen ja
natürlich also angegriffen schlicht und
ergreifend dadurch dass er sich an das
system ist orientiert und aufgestellt
hat also das ist glaub ich klar ich
glaube darum gibt es auch konsens in
dieser runde auf wann würden sie sagen
schon immer oder irgendwann nee ich
würde das so wie frau beck situieren
also nuller jahre ja und da sind dann
die wir also entwicklungen absehbar
bekommen ja dann in die diskussion rein
warum hat man es sozusagen politisch
nicht ernst genommen oder ernst nehmen
wollen das hat natürlich was damit zu
tun dass man ja auch nach 1989 der
theorie angehangen hat dem ökonomischen
wandel wird auch der politische wandel
folgende liberalisierung
demokratisierung leider ein großer
irrtum vor dem wir jetzt stehen da würde
ich gerne noch mal nachfragen hat der
westen tatsächlich vielleicht aus
wirtschaftspolitischen gründen vor allen
dingen sich diesen konflikten stück weit
auch verweigert na klar absolut also ich
meine das ist ja nun wirklich der
wie soll man sagen das paradigma gewesen
also erstmal wirtschaft hat das primat
vor allem und dann entsprechend auch in
der organisation internationaler politik
dann müssen wir uns ja auch heute nicht
naiv stellen also welche verhältnisse
wie zu welchen ländern heute noch
fliegen jetzt ist die große
desillusionierung eingetreten was
russland angeht aber ich meine die
arabischen länder sind nun auch nicht
gerade wie sagt man sagen die die
homeland soft demokratie und
menschenrechte und dergleichen ja es
geht aber unvermindert weiter
beziehungsweise jetzt im angesicht der
energieproblematik noch mal verschärft
und insofern verhebt der westen izmir
verbracht definieren was das ist
verschiebt sich sozusagen noch immer in
dieser personalie liegt darin auch ein
stückweit überheblichkeit professor
görtemaker von seiten der westlichen
demokratien naja die westlichen
demokratien haben natürlich über sehr
lange zeiträume hinweg geglaubt dass das
ein universelles prinzip seit wir lernen
jetzt dass es überhaupt kein
universelles prinzip ist sondern dass
die demokratie im grunde ein westliches
konzept ist bezogen natürlich auf
westeuropa von wo es auch ausgegangen
ist und nordamerika natürlich gibt es
einige andere regionen in denen sich
demokratie auch durchsetzen konnte und
auch behauptet hat wenn wir in
australien/neuseeland denken oder einige
andere länder aber im großen und ganzen
wenn man das weltweit betrachtet ist die
demokratie wie sie es am anfang gesagt
haben nicht nur auf dem rückzug sondern
sie war nie wirklich universell
der anspruch wurde hoben insbesondere
natürlich auch in der menschenrechts
charta der vereinten nationen und mit
der gründung der vereinten nationen oder
vorher schon mit dem völkerbund aber
auch das waren amerikanische konzepte
wenn man so will von mo do listen oder
dann eben auch von franklin delano
roosevelt das hat sich nicht
durchgesetzt und wir lernen heute dass
es eben große bereiche in der welt gibt
denen wir zwar gerne die errungenschaft
der demokratie bringen wollen die aber
selber aus ihrer eigenen geschichte aus
ihrer tradition heraus andere
vorstellungen von von gesellschaft haben
das müssen wir zunächst mal akzeptieren
die frage ist dann wie wir damit umgehen
zum ende des sowjetimperiums gab es ja
von foucault ja mal den satz das ende
der geschichte ist ein stückweit
erreicht was meinte dass jetzt sozusagen
alle länder in demokratien sich
transformieren sie haben es gerade schon
widerlegt dass diese these mit dem
jetzigen zeitpunkt wo wir auch
geradestehen
krieg gegen die ukraine et cetera ist
das nicht jetzt besonders widerlegt oder
nochmal ja also die diese these von
francis fukuyama hat eigentlich nie
jemand ernst genommen das war natürlich
ein gag eines eines
politikwissenschaftlers der damit
berühmt geworden ist in amerika ist die
lust auf station wichtig für jede
berufung das heißt man muss möglichst
oft zitiert werden und selbst wenn man
den großen runden behauptet es gibt kein
ende der geschichte hat es nie gegeben
und wird es auch in zukunft nicht geben
jetzt stehen wir sozusagen einer
zeitenwende das ist vollkommen richtig
aber ein ende der geschichte hat es
nicht gegeben die hoffnung waren
natürlich nach 1989 90 dass wir
sozusagen in ein zeitalter des friedens
eintreten würden dass wir es dass es
möglich sein könnte über verhandlungen
oder auch über wirtschaftliche
entwicklung dann eine bessere zukunft zu
bauen das hat sich jetzt auch als irrtum
erwiesen insofern ist das eben auch ein
ende der illusionen die wir uns gemacht
haben und nicht nur eine zeitenwende
noch eine frage an den an den historiker
ist der systemkonflikt wenn man sich die
geschichte sozusagen als ganzes ein
stückweit betrachtet
nicht systemimmanent muss nicht gerade
der wechsel der herrschaftssysteme
kommen das ist nicht sozusagen auch fast
ein muss also ich glaube er wird genau
das vorhin schon sehr deutlich gesagt es
gibt unterschiedliche wege dass sich
dinge verändern
manchmal sind das ideologien die hier
wirksam werden dann ist es wiederum
macht politik die dazu führt die
geopolitik spielt auch eine gewisse
rolle das heißt dass unterschiedliche
faktoren die dazu führen dass sich
verhältnisse grundlegend ändern aber
dass er sich grundlegend ändern das ist
eine ur erfahrung der geschichte das war
in der antike nicht anders als es heute
ist und das wird auch immer so bleiben
insofern wäre meint
aufzuwachen und tatsächlich
realpolitisch zu denken und nicht
irgendwelchen wunsch träumen und
illusionen nachzuhängen
ich habe gesagt ich würde das gerne noch
so ein bisschen sozial
soziologisch sozusagen betrachten gucken
wir doch mal auf diese gesellschaften
die nach demokratien streben und diese
demokratien dann aber dann doch im laufe
der zeit an attraktivität verlieren das
ist ja der prozess der moment in vielen
staaten stattfindet was die gründe dafür
denn eigentlich müsste man aus unserer
sicht ja sagen also wir haben so viel
freiheit das kann doch eigentlich nur
jeden erfreuen aber ist ja andere dinge
mal ein stichwort zur freiheit wir haben
sozusagen einen empathischen positiven
begriff von freiheit
das hat was mit der geschichte zu tun es
hat etwas mit der verfasstheit unseres
staates und unserer gesellschaft zu tun
aber psychologisch betrachtet ist
freiheit nicht nur attraktiv freiheit
bedeutet auch ich muss selber
entscheiden ich muss mir selber ein
urteil bilden ich muss
mich sozusagen im kantischen sinne auf
mein eigenes urteilsvermögen beziehen
können usw das ist ja nicht immer leicht
und es gibt einen großen wunsch ich fand
diesen freiheits zumutungen entlang zu
entlasten und zu sagen ich stimme mal zu
oder ich lasse mir sagen was das
richtige ist dann habe ich sozusagen
eine große entlastung zu wirkungen
insofern müssen wir nicht glauben dass
der gedanke stammt von hannah arendt die
das sehr prägnant gesagt hat mit der mit
der freiheit als belastung und insofern
müssen wir nicht glauben dass das
sozusagen in sich schon für eine
gesellschaft etwas erstrebenswertes ist
und damit hängt zusammen das ist
natürlich eine verlockung gibt bestimmte
politik angebote anzunehmen die von den
freiheits zumutungen auch entlasten ja
also zum beispiel und das wäre der
nächste punkt weil sie trat klar sagt wo
es lang geht oder irgendjemand dann ein
diktator oder wer auch immer das sagt
oder google oder sowas ja aber das muss
man sehen und der andere punkt ist und
da laufen wir sozusagen
mitten rein in unsere diskussion dass
wir krisenhafter die entwicklungen
werden desto größer wird das
orientierungs defizit was menschen
empfinden also wir kommen ja gut durch
die welt wenn wir wissen wie die sachen
laufen wenn es mal kleinere fraktionen
und sonstwas gibt okay dann kriegt man
das irgendwie hin wenn wir jetzt aber
viele situationen nacheinander haben mit
großflächigen auswirkungen ohne dass ein
skript vorliegt auch für die politische
klasse kein skript vorliegt was müssen
wir denn jetzt machen wir müssen wir
denn jetzt in irgendeiner weise
handlungen organisieren und sowas dann
entsteht ein riesiges orientierungs
defizit menschen mögen aber nicht
situationen der desorientierung mangels
also versucht man irgend etwas zu finden
was orientierung herstellt und das
wieder derselbe punkt orientierung
herstellen kann man mit einfachen
aussagen mit einfachen strategien mit
einfachen die utopien und so und das ist
an sich natürlich nicht gut für die
demokratie weil die demokratie leider
gewissermaßen keinen keine
gesellschaftsform der einfachheit ist es
komplizierter und komplexer frau beck
wenn wir da in diesem zusammenhang doch
mal nach russland schauen würden sie
sagen es hat nach dem zusammenbruch des
sowjetimperiums mal eine situation
gegeben wo russland sich sehr viel
stärker in richtung demokratie hätte
entwickeln können also wenn man in die
90er jahre zurück geht und mit den
menschen spricht die freiheit wollten
was für sie bedeutet hat unter anderem
auch aufarbeitung der geschichte der
eigenen unterdrückung wir haben ja fast
keine vorstellung davon wie der stalin
terror ganz tief in die gesellschaft
hinein gegangen ist und das ist
eigentlich fast keine familie gibt aus
der sowjetunion die nicht in irgendeiner
weise durch diesen staatlichen terror
der ja auch so willkürlich war der
bedeutet hat es kann immer einer aus
unserer familie in den gulag geschickt
werden
dieser also es gab schon
viele die das gefühl hatten wenn wir das
nicht uns anschauen was das mit uns als
gesellschaft gemacht hat dann haben wir
keine chance
und dafür gehört die die viele
inzwischen steht mit moral moskau die ja
nicht nur in moskau sondern tatsächlich
in der gesamten im gesamten sowjetunion
gearbeitet haben
wenn man mit den spricht sagen die die
90er jahre waren extrem schwierig weil
sie ökonomisch so schwierig waren es
wirklich also bis hin zu der sorge wie
ernähre ich mich schwere jahre waren
aber es waren jahre in denen die türen
aufgemacht werden durfte und man hinter
die türen schauen konnte und es waren
jahre der chance es gab die
pressefreiheit ist durfte gesprochen
werden es gab nicht mehr nur den
küchentisch hinter dem in der familie
gesprochen werden durfte aber schon
nicht mehr aus sagt der tür das wurde
als ganz ganz große chance empfunden und
ich glaube es ist ein drama dass
russland nicht die zeit bekommen hat um
auf diesem weg weiter zu gehen andere
länder die entlassen worden sind aus der
sowjetunion
haben sich haben diesen weg ja weiter
beschritten also sowohl die die aus dem
warschauer pakt entlassen worden sind
man nehme polen
die man nehme die baltischen staaten
aber eben auch andere jetzt
selbstständige republiken und die
ukraine
für russland ist das so tragisch weil
die zeiten eigentlich wieder so dunkel
geworden sind wie unter stalins zeiten
und putin hat ja auch sehr systematisch
an sehr viele bilder und mythen
angeknüpft die stalins stärke begründet
haben also der mythos vom großen
vaterländischen krieg der mythos vom
sieg gegen die faschisten das sind alles
bilder die von live nation bemüht werden
oben diese repression nach innen mit dem
krieg nach außen über einen ander zu
bringen und es funktioniert leider
ziemlich gut wenn wir das von frau beck
höheren hertgen inwiefern trifft der
westen denn dann auch ein stück weit mit
schuld im prozess der automatisierung
russlands wollen jetzt nicht putins
negativfolgen aber inwiefern wenn wir
von gemeinsame europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur sprechen wenn wir
davon sprechen dass obama mal gesagt hat
russland ist gerade mal nur
regionalmacht etc trifft uns da auch ein
stück weit mit schuld in
anführungszeichen also ich glaube wir
müssen die
die fälle unterscheiden
bei denen wir fragen gibt es eine
verantwortung schuld des westens das
eine ist die innere entwicklung darüber
haben sie gerade gesprochen
automatisierung das andere ist die
äußere entwicklung der krieg da glaube
ich muss man die rolle des westens sehr
unterschiedlich sehen
was was wobei sie eine entwicklung über
lange zeit ist na ja aber die sind ja
und sie hängen natürlich auch
miteinander zusammen aber trotzdem sind
es gerade was die rolle des westens oder
europas anbelangt glaube ich sehr
unterschiedliche entwicklungen vorweg
hat ja die 90er jahre beschrieben als
show als frei also relativ freiheitliche
phase mit großen chancen aber mit
ökonomischen chaos so da wäre jetzt die
frage hätte der westen mehr tun können
zur ökonomischen stabilisierung russland
um der freiheit entwicklung eine
wirtschaftliche basis zu geben da habe
ich jedenfalls kein urteil das muss ich
das ja da habe ich auch noch nicht noch
genug nachgedacht ich bin skeptisch ich
glaube das nicht glaube er dass das
innere entwicklungen waren bei denen ist
die die äußeren einwirkungsmöglichkeiten
schwer gegeben hat denn zur freiheit
gehörte ja im grunde ein bild des
kapitalismus die oligarchie sierung ist
ja in dieser phase erfolgt und dann
diese diese wirtschaftliche also was
heute und gefördert worden auch
gefördert worden so zu sagen es war ein
zerfall sind keine strukturen aufgebaut
worden die alten waren weg kaputt die
sowjetunion in ihren strukturen
existierten nicht mehr
und dieses wie soll ich mal sagen
unvorbereitete jetzt wird alles frei hat
dazu geführt dass durch die stärkeren
hat zu diesem wildwest kapitalismus
geführt der das wirtschaftliche system
und die wirtschaftliche entwicklung
diskreditiert und und und so desaströs
gemacht hat dass sie auf die politik
gewirkt hat in dem sinne dass gesagt
wurde was diese freiheit mag schon sein
aber wenn das land im chaos ist und wir
uns nicht nicht genug zum essen haben
dann rufen wir den starken mann als er
sehe ich den die rolle des westens
eigentlich schwächer
das sehe ich so nicht in der anderen
frage krieg
und die entwicklung spätestens ab 20 14
annexion der krim und was sich daraus
ergeben hat da glaube ich
da ist da hat der westen sich so
verhalten
würde ich mal die these ist eine
hypothetische these aber ich wollte die
these wagen
dass der westen durch sein verhalten zu
der fehleinschätzung
von putin in der entscheidung für den
krieg gegen die ukraine der westen zu
der fehleinschätzung putins beigetragen
hat diese europäer musst du nicht sehr
ernst nehmen diesen westen musst du
nicht sehr ernst nehmen ich habe die
krim annektiert bin interveniert in die
ost ukraine militärisch also die die die
provozierenden
evidenten brutalsten
völkerrechtsverletzungen die man sich
vorstellen kann und ein jahr später habe
ich nur zwei verabredet ein jahr später
durfte gazprom den größten gasspeicher
auch noch kaufen und es gab empörung
aber keine konsequente politik die
gesagt hat bis hierhin und nicht weiter
wir meinen es wirklich ernst ein paar
kleine grüne männchen die immer gesagt
haben und ich glaube in dieser in ihrer
konsequenz also empörung und dann aber
wieder keine konsequenzen folgen glaube
ich haben wir
es muss man sagen dazu beigetragen dass
putin in seiner folgen kalkulation was
bedeutet der krieg kann ich ihn managen
wie wird der westen reagieren den westen
die europäer insbesondere aber auch die
amerikaner glaube ich aufgrund der
erfahrung zum beispiel afghanistan kurz
vorher der totalen rückzug
nicht wirklich so eingeschätzt hat wie
der westen sich dann verhalten hat
nämlich sehr geschlossen sehr
einheitlich und nun sehr relativ nicht
konsequent genug aber relativ konsequent
und ich glaube diese fehlende
abschreckung ist ein beitrag zur
fehlkalkulation und damit zur
entscheidung putins und für den christen
das ist schon der schuldfrage schon
sehr wichtig
in russland zu gehen
dieses große chaos kann man ja fast
niemanden vorwerfen niemand hatte eine
vorstellung wie man eine so große
volkswirtschaft ein so riesiges land wie
man das transformieren soll aus dem
staats wirtschaftlichen in ein
marktwirtschaftliches system und wenn
man sich überlegt wie schwer wir uns
schon von relativ schwer getan haben mit
uni war liga ex ddr das problem ist
glaube ich und das hätten wir vielleicht
bis hin zu unseren nachrichtensystemen
wissen können es gab eine struktur die
sich erhalten hat und das war der kgb
und der kgb wusste auch wo die gelder
waren und es ist nichts neu entstanden
in russland in den 90er jahren auch die
oligarchen nicht ohne dass der kgb mit
dabei war es gibt keine einzige gründung
die struck die kgb struktur hat sich
durchgezogen und putin ist auch nicht
der kleine offizier aus dresden gewesen
der auf einmal man konnte es sich gar
nicht erklären von yates ihn ausgesucht
worden war sondern die schritte wurden
sehr viel systematischer gesetzt da
können wir uns gern hinterher da haben
wir darüber austauschen trete ich gerne
gegen sie an röttgen das ist eine sehr
systematischen strategie gewesen und
insofern ist diese mischung aus mafiösen
strukturen also wirklich bereicherung in
einer schamlosigkeit dass wir uns dass
wir sie fast nicht begreifen können und
dieser geheimdienst struktur dahinter
und der art des denkens mit der wir
jetzt konfrontiert werden also wie putin
ein herrn marco genügt an koffer
demütigt das ist ja jetzt noch
öffentlich geworden das ist richtig kgb
system nämlich immer volle fahrt voraus
und mal gucken dass ich den anderen
schon mal an die wand nageln und mit
sowas sind wir gar nicht in der lage
gewesen um zu gehen der göttinger wir
sprechen heute über den konflikt
demokratie autokratie wie putinka
autokratie wenn wir die betrachten auch
in dem wie es sich entwickelt hat so
kamen ja gerade stichworte kgb und so
weiter strebt vor allen dingen auch nach
erlangung imperialer macht so könnte man
es nennen geht dieser imperiale geist
vor allem mit dem automatismus einher
oder wenn wir die demokratien betrachten
gibt es da so etwas auch es gibt viele
beispiele dafür dass auch demokratien
nach imperialer macht streben das
britische empire ist eigentlich nichts
anderes gewesen die usa haben nun sich
wirklich nicht zurückgehalten nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg was also die
ausweitung ihrer macht betraf also das
ist nicht aber autokratien beschränkt
aber was was putin an betrifft da kann
ich ihnen also eigentlich auch da nur
zustimmen
putin war eine ordnungsmacht der kgb war
eine ordnungsmacht in einer chaotischen
situation in russland 90er jahren jelzin
hat ihn ja nicht umsonst in diese
position gebracht um tatsächlich so
etwas wie eine eine neue stabilität
herzustellen
aber das interessante ist dass putin
natürlich nicht nur sozusagen kgb
gesteuert war so dass er auch ein
konzept hatte nach dem ende der
sowjetunion tatsächlich so etwas wie
einen einen außenpolitischen
revisionismus anzustreben und wenn nicht
die gesamte alte sowjetunion wieder
herzustellen das wird sicherlich nicht
möglich sein aber doch so viel russische
erde zu sammeln wie es irgendwie geht
und das bezieht sich natürlich nicht nur
auf
großen nie oder tschetschenien oder eben
auf georgien wo es ja früher diese
konflikte gab sondern wenn man sich die
putin die welt vorstellt dann sieht man
dass das eben natürlich noch sehr viel
weiter geht und die ukraine eben
einbezieht was er eben auch als
russische erde versteht die frage ist wo
wird er wo wird der halt machen wird er
in der ukraine halt machen oder sogar
schon im donbass oder wird er weiter
gehen das weiß keiner von uns und
deswegen ist es umso wichtiger in diesem
imperialen gefüge in dem wir uns nun
einmal bewegen nicht nur von seiten der
autokratien sondern auch von seiten der
demokratien tatsächlich zu sehen werden
wir unsere eigenen werte verteidigen
wollen müssen wir etwas dafür tun und
das heißt also wie das im armeebericht
von 1967 so schön formulierte
entspannung und sicherheit müssen eine
gegenseitige ergänzung bilden das heißt
wenn wir eine vernünftige weltordnung
haben wollen die uns nicht auf die füsse
welt dann müssen wir auch für zukunft
wird etwas für unsere sicherheit tun der
bundeskanzler hat ja da sozusagen einen
ersten ersten anlauf gemacht aber die
200 milliarden plus erreichung des 2
prozent ziels wäre das minimum dessen
was wir brauchen werden wir nicht bereit
sind für unsere sicherheit etwas zu tun
und die militärischen fähigkeiten zu
entwickeln wird jemand wie putin uns
niemals respektieren und das ist
entscheidend und wir haben über viele
jahre gedacht dass das nicht mehr nötig
sei das eben die vernunft eingekehrt sei
das eben über vernünftige
handelsbeziehungen auch über
interdependenz gegenseitige
abhängigkeiten tatsächlich so etwas wie
ein gemeinsamer geist möglich sein wird
und das hat sich als irrtum erwiesen ein
blick in die geschichte hätte gereicht
dass das niemals genügt dass man immer
etwas für sich tun muss und für seine
eigene sicherheit wenn man vom gegner
respektiert werden will insofern ist es
eigentlich auch egal ob jemand aus
ideologischen gründen wie früher im
kommunismus sagen wir mal die
weltherrschaft anstrebt oder eben aus
imperium geist es ist völlig
gleichgültig das ergebnis ist immer
dasselbe und deswegen kommt es auf das
eigene verhalten sehr stark an wie man
damit umgeht und ob man mit seinen
eigenen vorstellungen erfolgreich sein
kann
der welt sein wenn wir das hören dass
hertha gerade gesagt hat und von diesem
gemeinsamen geist ausgehen haben wir
dann stück wird auch zu wenig getan um
diesen gemeinsamen geist zum erfolg zu
führen na ja die frage wie man das macht
die gemeinsamen geist zum erfolg zu
führen das würde ja schonmal
voraussetzen dass dieser geist
nicht irgendwie ein doppelbödiger ist
also es muss eine identität zwischen den
ansprüchen den werten dem geist und dem
handeln vorhanden sein das ist etwas was
dem westen natürlich aus sicht anderer
gesellschaften immer vorgeworfen wird
dass diese identität nicht besteht ja
insofern treffe es nie erläutert naja
nehmen wir einfach länder des globalen
südens postkoloniale gesellschaften und
so weiter die natürlich ein bild vom
westen haben aufgrund der kolonialen
vergangenheit auch was was die die
werthaltigkeit zu sagen dieser form von
staaten stark anzweifelte und zwar auf
der grundlage von gemachter historischer
erfahrung so also insofern ist das mit
dem geist den man dann verbreitet eine
der muss ja auch gewissermaßen
akzeptabel sein und glaubwürdig sein und
das ist es dann vielfach nicht aber ich
würde gerne noch mal ein ganz anderen
punkt in die imperialismus frage bringen
ich glaube man kann davon ausgehen dass
diese immer dass wir eine renaissance
des imperialismus haben die beispiele
russland china und so was sind die
prägnantesten aber nicht die einzigen
und die große frage ist doch wie so
kommt das jetzt eigentlich im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert zurück
also sozusagen unsere erwartungen an
demokratisierung haben sich enttäuscht
aus vielen gründen haben wir schon
vielfach darüber geredet aber was ist
eigentlich wenn wir das klassische was
für imperiale denker wichtig ist
zunehmend weniger haben nämlich land wir
haben große ökologische probleme wir
haben eine erhitzung die viele regionen
unbewohnbar macht wir sehen dass
ressourcen ganz banale ressourcen
weniger werden kleiner werden wenn ich
jetzt einen start habe der an sich schon
räuberisch ist wie russland und
gewissermaßen den anspruch auf
universalismus sowieso überhaupt nicht
hat und andere autokratische systeme
eben diesen universellen anspruch nicht
haben sondern die wollen ja für uns für
ihre leute irgendwas sichern dann ist
sozusagen der umweltfaktor glaube ich
einer der gründe dafür dass wir in paris
es muss zurückbekommen das heißt nicht
dass putin jetzt selber sozusagen das im
sinne hat aber wir wissen halt aus der
geschichte dass bestimmte akteure dinge
agieren die sozusagen an derzeit sind ja
und dafür formen finden und deshalb habe
ich die befürchtung dass das imperiale
zeitalter gewissermaßen noch vor uns
liegt weil diese basalen
verteilungskämpfe werden deutlich
intensiver werden und dann ist die frage
und das war ja die eingangsfrage hier
haben demokratien mit ihren
universalistischen ansprüchen denn eine
chance gegen diesen partikularismus zu
bestehen
[Musik]
ich doch
gegen diese düsteren blick auf die
zukunft ein bisschen gegen halten würde
sicherlich kann man sagen dass wir in
der tendenz immer zu spät sind und immer
ein bisschen zu langsam sind aber wenn
man sich alleine den g 7 gipfel jetzt
anschaut der doch zu seinem hauptthema
gemacht hat dass alle verstanden haben
dass diese ökologische frage in all
ihren facetten mit den klimatischen
veränderungen mit der mit der ressourcen
frage
dass die uns alle betrifft und dass wir
an ganz ganz vielen stellen akteure
brauchen um
tatsächlich so zu leben und so zu
produzieren dass wir auch mit den
nächsten generationen ein gutes leben
auf dieser welt haben aber ich habe das
gefühl dass das sehr verstanden wird
dass es verstanden wird zb in viel mehr
bereichen der industrie als wie gerne er
gerade aus so grosser motto
antikapitalistischen kreisen formuliert
wird
erstaunlicherweise ist eigentlich die
marktwirtschaft und seine akteure in der
lage viel beweglicher und viel schneller
zu reagieren auf veränderungen die
notwendig sind als ein großes
totalitäres system wir sehen das jetzt
finde ich an cupid sehr gut wie schwer
china sich tut mit cupid so umzugehen
das ist nicht dem eigenen land massiv
schadet wir haben uns letztlich unterm
strich besser geschlagen auch wenn wir
das zu anfang nicht so ausgesehen hat
und insofern
glaube ich gab es immer in bayern so
phasen der großen modernisierung und
veränderung die weber die wir alle in
der schule gelesen haben es gab dann
immer tiefe verunsicherung zeigten von
depressionen aber letztlich hat es doch
immer auch wieder einen weg nach vorne
gelesen oder ist
es ruhig das kommt noch mal sagen darf
es haben trotzdem mehr menschen zugang
zu medizinischer versorgung
es ist in den letzten jahren bis jetzt
mit dem krieg
aufwärts gegangen mit der
ernährungssituation der meisten kinder
auf dieser welt also dieses der
kapitalismus hat die länder des südens
alle noch viel ärmer gemacht stimmt so
nicht wenn man bedauern das hat es schon
erstaunlich wie sie als als grüne die
empirie aller ökologischen und
klimatologischen sachverhalte vollkommen
ignorieren das ist doch was völlig
verrücktes wir haben jetzt spreche
darüber wie es am besten bewältigt
werden ja weil mich jetzt zu trauern
aber die bewältigung sagen wir mal 50
jahre nach erscheinen der grenzen des
wachstums da sind wir heute ungefähr auf
den tag genau übrigens er hat keine
bewältigung stattgefunden wir sind in
allen werten egal ob es die emissionen
angeht ob es diese zustand der senken
ist ob es die vermüllung der meere und
sonst was ist
katastrophal viel schlechter als vor 50
jahren von welcher welt sprechen also
ich kann ins ein beispiel bringen über
die wandlungsfähigkeit wenn man sich
anschaut wie weit ist möglich gewesen
ist den energieverbrauch und die
produktivität zu ent groß ist ein gutes
beispiel dafür dass menschliche
intelligenz gibt es gar nicht die einen
menschlichen intelligenz auch die gibt
uns hoffnung wenn wir sehen wie die
welternährungs möglichkeiten sich
verbessert im grunde genommen herr welt
klingen sie wie herr markus der um die
19 jahrhundert gesagt hat diese erde
gibt nicht mehr her als eine milliarde
menschen zu ende und jetzt sind 47
hunger ja aber wie ex werden gut ernährt
wenn da das thema das ist ja dann schon
der hunger gewähren auch gerne ein stück
weit wieder zu unserem thema kommen herr
röttgen würde gerne nochmal auf die
demokratischen werte auch ein stück weit
schauen wir haben ja sehr oft in den
letzten wochen und monaten das bild
bemüht dass wir in der ukraine unsere
werte dass unsere werte dort auch
verteidigt werden müssen ein stück weit
da stellt sich dann ja die frage wir
werden also die demokratischen werte
jetzt nicht mehr am hindukusch sondern
eher im dom bass verteidigt oder wie
sollte man das sehen wie
ich man muss ist so sehen nach meiner
einschätzung
das sagte ich eingangs und kann darauf
mich beziehen
putin geht es um einen historischen
revisionismus also er will dieses europa
und seine politische landkarte wie es
sich am ende des kalten krieges ergeben
hat nämlich mit dem ende des warschauer
paktes mit dem ende der sowjetunion mit
einem europa das sich geeinigt hat in
der
in der pariser
schlussakkord auf carta in der charta
von paris der nachfolge vereinbarung zu
der schlussakte von helsinki
das war wie george bush der ältere
damals gesagt hat ein europa das ist ein
ganzes europa ein vereintes europa ein
freies europa und im frieden das war
eben haben sie von dem kantischen moment
gesprochen wir dachten wir haben uns
jetzt verständigt auf die prinzipien des
zusammenlebens der respektierung des
anderen staates und das ist unsere
europäische friedensordnung die haben
wir gehabt darum dachten wir sind davon
kann das ist der ewige wir haben jetzt
festgestellt ich meine 2014 spätestens
jedenfalls die ewigkeit hat nur 25 jahre
gedauert und mit diesem krieg jetzt
greift putin diese politische ordnung
das was sich ergeben hat als das als als
das ende des kalten krieges nämlich wie
sie eben beschrieben aber vereint in
frieden und freiheit das greift er an er
greift es an indem er das zentrale
prinzip von zentrale prinzipien verletzt
nämlich das recht des staates zu
existieren seinen eigenen weg zu wählen
einen freien weg zu wählen mit dem
mittel des krieges und damit auch über
diese europäische ordnung hinaus ein
bruch des völkerrechts das ist das was
er angreift und das steht auf dem spiel
wenn er damit erfolg hat das ist unser
europäisches anleger die ukraine kämpfen
um ihr leben aber es geht um diese
ordnung wenn er damit erfolg hat wenn
also der krieg als mittel der politik in
europa im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
als wir im 19 jahrhundert geführt wurde
wieder eingeführt wird dann werden wir
einen gespaltenen kontinent haben dann
wird der krieg weiter gehen weil er sich
gelohnt hat wenn er sich durchsetzt bis
nach orders geografisch zu sagen dann
ist die ukraine dann ist die republik
moldau geschluckt und erledigt
chancenlos in georgien geht es weiter
dann einen ein gespaltenes europa in der
östlichen im östlichen teil gibt es die
dominanz einer aggressiven macht und
auch das wird weitergehen es wird im
mittleren osten in syrien weiter gehen
in nordafrika libyen es geht in der
sahel zone weiter
migrationsfragen werden ausgelöst in
europa zu destabilisieren hunger wird
ein gesetz als politische waffe
flüchtlinge werden eingesetzt als
politische waffe cyberattacken wir
werden getrennte wenn der 1 es ist wenn
erstmal der krieg sich bewährt als
mittel der politik im ganz amoralischen
sinne dann laufen wir auf eine auf sehr
schwierige jahre zu und darum darum geht
es und darum sterben oder dafür kämpfen
die ukraine doch und das ist auch ein
grund warum wir sie unterstützen sollten
und nicht wie manchmal diskreditieren
gesagt weil die frau beck und der rolle
und so emotional sind oder weil sie
moralisch sondern aus unserem interesse
heraus
einmal nachhaken also der krieg der
wieder eingeführt ist wie herr röttgen
es sagt muss der westen müssen die
westlichen demokratien darauf auch mit
waffen antworten sie haben gar keine
andere wahl als das zu tun natürlich
müssen sie das tun ich würde gern noch
einen gedanken bevor das gleich nochmal
aufgreifen
black sagen ich sehe ihn vorkommen zu
dass demokratien lernfähiger sind als
autokratien da sind wir glaube ich auch
einer meinung sie sind nur sehr viel
langsamer als autokratien und deswegen
braucht das manchmal sehr viel zeit bis
sie reagieren was wir jetzt diskutieren
hat ist genau eine konsequenz dessen das
heißt also wir haben lange gebraucht zu
verstehen wie putin tatsächlich denkt
wie er agiert und sehr lange haben wir
eben auch die augen davor verschlossen
obwohl wir es hätten sehen können wir
sollten auch die augen nicht davor
verschließen dass auch die ukraine keine
demokratie ist sondern sie ist
vielleicht auf dem weg zu demokratie
aber ist bis zum 24 februar waren wir
alle der meinung dass das dort eben
tatsächlich sehr viel korruption
herrscht und die oligarchen also eine
eine wichtige rolle spielen und das tun
sie ja auch in der tat aber
insofern sie haben vollkommen recht wir
müssen einfach sehen dass das der gegner
nicht die ukraine ist oder oder ein audi
gleichen system in der ukraine sondern
dass der gegner tatsächlich punkten ist
die frage die die mich aber viel mehr
beschäftigt ist das gilt ja ein gewisser
weise auch wie china wir haben ja auch
als als als bundesregierung oder eben
gerade auch die union mit mit frau
merkel sehr lange nur nach osten gesehen
wir haben den feind er im westen
ausgemacht insbesondere bei hellen kramp
das war natürlich auch ein schwerer
fehler das heißt also wir müssen einfach
wahrnehmen wie die welt ist und die
frage ist was geschieht eigentlich wenn
der ukraine krieg mal zu ende ist wird
russland die ukraine tatsächlich
sozusagen entlassen aus ihrem
herrschaftsbereich wird sie sogar den
den bass wieder räume ich kann mir das
sehr schwer vorstellen genauso wenig wie
die krim das heißt man wird irgendwann
auch realpolitisch und das gehört eben
auch zum ende der illusionen mit
russland wieder reden müssen vielleicht
mit putin oder seinem nachfolger wie
auch immer auf jeden fall bleibt
russland natürlich eine starke macht mit
der zu rechnen sein wird eine aggressive
macht oder eine potenziell aggressive
macht auch das ist richtig aber das
schließt aber das schließt nicht aus
aber das schließt nicht aus dass man
wieder miteinander umgehen muss in
irgendeiner form und das gleiche gilt
natürlich für china wir haben ja nicht
nur in russland eben eine starke
aggressive macht china geht anders vor
aber die neue seidenstraße ist nichts
anderes als auch eine herausforderung
des westens das heißt also wir haben
hier mit einem doppelten systemkonflikt
zu tun wenn sie so wollen und das ist im
imperiales denken was wir uns auch tief
in die ökologie hinein greift sie werden
in dieser welt nicht in bewegung bringen
können wenn wir china und russland da
nicht einbeziehen der größte teil des
co2 ausstoßes erfolg in china aber nicht
bei uns in der bundesrepublik wir sind
also im grunde
gar ein ganz geringer faktor china ist
ein riesiger faktor in china nicht
einbezogen wird dann kann die g7
beschließen was sie will es wird nichts
es wird nichts nützen also insofern in
der tat wir müssen tatsächlich die welt
zur kenntnis nehmen so wie sie ist und
dazu gehört eben auch russland in die
gespräche wieder einzubeziehen genauso
wie china wir sind herr welt noch nicht
sozusagen so weit dass wir russland in
die gespräche wieder mit einbeziehen wir
sind zurzeit bei dem thema waffenhilfe
was auch ein stück weit die wehrhafte
demokratie zeigen soll
heißt das denn im umkehrschluss dass wir
ohne waffenlieferungen keine wehrhafte
demokratie an den tag legen würden das
kann man allgemein natürlich so
überhaupt nicht sagen aber ich glaube es
kommt auf die konkrete situation und
auch die entwicklung des krieges an und
wir haben im moment ja doch eine prekäre
situation nach allem was man mal was man
sieht was das vorrücken der russischen
armee angeht was die erfolge der
russischen armee angeht und was das
verhältnis angeht also wir sprechen bei
atb wie von einem verhältnis von eins zu
zehn ungefähr also 10 hat die russische
armee
die ukraine beziehungsweise das was da
an geliefert wird jetzt muss man ja mal
die frage stellen wie soll dieser krieg
denn weitergehen
und so sehe ich herrn röttgen sozusagen
auf der emphatischen ebene zustimme und
auch dem realismus zustimme dass wir
gewissermaßen in ein zeitalter gehen wo
die frage der verteidigung der
sicherheit der kriegsführung
bereitschaft und so weiter eine
notwendigkeit ist auch wenn man es nicht
mag haben wir aber genau jetzt eine
situation wo man sich die frage stellen
muss ob die fortsetzung des krieges
inklusive die fütterung mit material
dieses krieges tatsächlich etwas ist was
zielführend ist was zu einem
wünschenswerten ergebnis führt oder aber
eine situation wie sie jetzt schon
herrscht sozusagen an sich intensivieren
denn krieg mit einer immer größer
werdenden opferzahl mit vollkommen
unklarem und wahrscheinlich schlechtem
ergebnis was die ziele angeht und
deshalb muss man glaube ich die den
unglückseliger weise die die den dänen
den erfolg der russischen armee jetzt
mal stärker zur kenntnis nehmen und auf
andere wege der beendigung dieses oder
bin ich es mal der unterbrechung des
krieges bringen das geht nicht das wird
sie können dafür so viele waffen reintun
sie werden das problem damit nicht lösen
ich komme gerade aus traf lange reise
inzwischen ich bin in den seit beginn
des krieges sind tief gewesen ich bin
und deshalb gewesen bin wieder in kiew
gewesen bin jetzt in kharkiv gewesen hf
ist ganz im osten der ukraine
etwa die hälfte der bevölkerung hat die
stadt verlassen die
außenbezirke sehen aus wie aleppo
150000 menschen vertrieben
aber das entscheidende herr welter ist
dass die menschen den kopf geblieben
sind alle sagen
wir wollen weiter kämpfen und wissen sie
aus welchem grund weil sie wissen dass
es ihnen unter russischer besatzung
extrem schlecht geht das ist der
entscheidende punkt mit dem wir uns
auseinandersetzen müssen ich weiß nicht
wie eng er kontakt des das hoch
humanitären organisationen also zum
beispiel komitee gegen folter amnesty
international human rights also was
passiert in den besetzten gebieten und
das war auch in der dnr lnr schon so
zwangsrekrutierung demand familien
müssen versuchen ihre männer zu
verstecken im keller weil die eingesetzt
werden als kanonenfutter in der front
gegen die russen die ukrainische armee
verschwindenlassen von menschen
folter
natürlich die sexualisierte gewalt gegen
frauen die es immer mit dabei es sind
inzwischen über eine millionen menschen
deportiert worden
nach russland gegen ihren willen sie
dürfen russland nicht verlassen es gibt
300.000 kinder die inzwischen
zwangsdeportiert worden sind und es gibt
inzwischen
zwangsadoption und rossini zierung wenn
sie das zusammennehmen haben die ukraine
nicht das gefühl ihre alternative wäre
real wir hören jetzt mal auf zu kämpfen
und wenn es erstmal ruhe dass das wäre
ja eine alternative über die man
nachdenken muss denn durch den krieg
sterben menschen das kann ich ja gar
nicht stimme ich ihnen sofort zu
sterben menschen ist jeden tag 200
ukrainische soldaten ganz zu schweigen
von den russischen soldaten auch dort
schicken die mütter und frauen ihre
männer nicht gerne in den krieg und es
ist grauenhaft dass das russische staat
nicht mal dafür sorgt dass die toten
körper zurückgeholt werden also putin
geht ja mit seinem volk auch ganz
fürchterlich um aber nochmal die
alternative die sie aufzeigen und die
auf den ersten blick so
vernünftig und rational und vielleicht
sogar die humanere zu sein scheint die
ist es nicht weil mit der russischen
besatzung der terror einzieht ja aber
sie und das ist das was die ukraine
wissen und deswegen kämpfen sie selbst
unter schlechten bedingungen weiter und
dann ist nur noch die frage ob wir sie
wir haben verstanden sie führen sogar
eine auseinandersetzung für uns weil
wenn sie verloren haben wird das
weiterkommen als nächstes dran sein wir
sind
nato-partner vorbeigekommen und dann
sind wir dran aber frau merkel sagt ich
würde gerne
könnt ihr gleich beim einer schlussfrage
oder meine schlussrunde die ich jetzt
ein leute gegenrichtung von daher wir
sind nämlich schon ziemlich weit
fortgeschritten herbert wenig fangen wir
mal ihnen an man hat ja den eindruck
dass die europäische friedensordnung
durch den angriff auf die ukraine ein
stückweit geschichte ist auf welcher
basis kann denn einen
waffenstillstand zu einer friedlichen
koexistenz
mit dem aggressor führen zwischen dem
demokratien des westens und russland
aber vielleicht eben auch immer ein
bisschen weiter zu fassen auch in bezug
auf china
also erstmal vielleicht russland ja
und
realpolitisch halte ich das für eine
illusion natürlich frau beck auch recht
seine illusion zu glauben dass der
waffenstillstand zu frieden führt so
lange nämlich die
imperialistische
ambitionen der wille von putin da ist
und daran gibt es keinen zweifel dass
dieser wille besteht wird er jede neue
taktische situation das wäre ein
waffenstillstand für seine zwecke
ausnutzen also die eigene armee auch
wieder regenerieren wieder aufbauen
qualifizieren und dann wenn es opportun
für ihn ist die nächste aktion starten
das glaube ich muss man sich einfach
realpolitisch klar machen putin hat an
seiner entschlossenheit kein bisschen
aufgegeben und zurückgeschraubt und
darum ist die ist es wäre es eine fatale
illusion zu glauben dass wenn mal jetzt
waffenstillstand wäre das zum ende des
krieges oder gar zufrieden führen würde
das glaube ich muss man nüchtern sehen
darum
glaube ich ist das so bitter es ist
schon wendet wenn sie auf web seite eben
die berechtigte frage gestellt kann man
die verteidigung rechtfertig das erst
mal ich glaube die erste adressat sind
die ukraine dies entscheiden müssen aber
wir unterstützen sie ja und darum müssen
wir die frage auch entscheiden und ich
glaube dass wenn sie sich nicht
verteidigen würden wäre für die ukraine
kein friede wurde gewalt herrschen und
es würde das auch für europa eintreten
was ich eben beschrieben habe und darum
glaube ich ist das
so schrecklich die folgen sind
das wichtigste das richtige unter den
möglichkeiten
nicht zu kapitulieren sondern zu kämpfen
um das eigene leben und um unsere
freiheit und um unsere europäische
freiheit und wenn sie auch so
pessimistisch was einen waffenstillstand
angeht
sagen wir mal so da bin ich wieder
pessimistische noch optimistisch ich
würde sagen es muss ganz einfach darum
gehen eine solche situation der
unterbrechung der eskalation von gewalt
irgendwie herbeizuführen durch irgendein
internationale initiative mit vielleicht
leuten die bislang noch nicht sozusagen
im spiel gewesen sind aus afrika oder
anderen regionen der welt weil und das
war das was ich gegen frau beck
einwänden wollte ein bisschen auch gegen
sie herr röttgen man kommt ja an der
empirie nicht vorbei wenn man nun
feststellt dieser krieg wird nicht zu
gewinnen sein was macht man denn seine
empirie in paris immer vergangenheit ist
eine prognose von ihr sie wissen kann
empirie ich das ist ihre entscheidung
das ist in dieser welt scheinbar haben
ja ja
ja also macht sonst beruflich vollkommen
andere sachen naja viel mit optimismus
und zukunft zu tun insofern sehr
scheinbar ich habe eben gesagt also
bevor wir in dieser schlussrunde gewesen
sind gesagt was im moment die
kräfteverhältnisse sind und wir haben
den sachverhalt und das ist keine
zukunftsprognose sondern es ist etwas
was man gegenwärtig sieht dass die
russische armee im moment ordentlich
geländegewinne macht ja natürlich
erheblich dann stimmt das ja
aber das sollte uns da jetzt der stelle
nicht
da müssen wir doch einfach
sehr mühsame sehr mühsame relativ
geringe mit erheblichen verlusten auf
beiden seiten versehene geländegewinne
die frage der ausdauerfähigkeit der
russische der russischen ansicht dass
punkt auf geht
nach russland gebracht aber gelassen
weil er warnt er schätze lassen sie
einmal im besser noch zu ecke also er
sieht nämlich nicht danach aus als sei
die erschöpfung auf seiten der russen
das große problem weil es sowohl vom
material also von der energie als auch
von der rekrutierung der soldaten
gewissermaßen das ende da überhaupt
nicht absehen war er sich und bei der
gegenwärtigen selbst waren wir doch mal
über den punkt den ich vorhin gesagt
habe wenn wir eine theorie verhältnis
von eins zu zehn haben meinen sie im
ernst man nimmt da noch mal sozusagen
die vereinfachung der waffenlieferungen
dazu und hat dann eine situation des
gleichstand und wenn man die situation
dass gleichstand das hätte hätte man
auch nur einen dauerhaften
zermürbungskrieg und noch gar nichts
gewonnen das heißt der punkt ist doch
ganz einfach der ist so wünschenswert
ihrer beider perspektiven ist ist die
denn überhaupt realistisch ist die ziel
führen und gleichzeitig haben wir ja
eine permanente steigerung dass ich
weiss ehrlich gestehen genau wir sind
sie sind leider schon fast am ende der
geraden nicht würde sie gerne auch so
ein bisschen weiter in die zukunft
blickend auch mit blick auf russland
fragen ist es denn vorstellbar dass das
putins russland eine demokratische um
erziehung erfahren kann wie einst die
westmächte ist mit hitler deutschland
gebracht haben also erfolgreich erstens
noch einmal im letzten punkt weil das
wichtig ist 1 1 einen waffenstillstand
und gar 1 frieden ist erst möglich wenn
russland erkannt hat dass es die ukraine
nicht vollständig besetzen kann und wenn
die ukraine einsieht dass es den don was
nicht zurückerobern kann dann haben wir
einen zustand in dem ein
waffenstillstand auch verhandlungen
möglich sind das zweite ist dass
russland bei der ganzen
geschichte die es nun mal hat im
zarenreich wie auch in der sowjetunion
und dann in den chaotischen
verhältnissen
danach mit einer kgb herrschaft am ende
dann über nacht zu einer demokratie
mutieren kann daran kann man ernsthaft
nicht glauben wenn man das deutsche
beispiel nimmt die die vorbedingung war
erstmal die bedingungslose kapitulation
45 und zweitens eine eine lange
demokratische vorgeschichte die früh im
19 jahrhundert beginnt und dann
natürlich auch eine fürchterliche weise
durch den nationalsozialismus
unterbrochen wurde aber eine solche
vorgeschichte von demokratischen
strukturen fehlt in russland ganz
einfach und deswegen wird der
transformationsprozess in russland zu
demokratischen verhältnissen wenn er
denn überhaupt stattfindet sehr viel
länger dauern welchen preis frau beck
müssen wir den zahlen für die
verteidigung unserer freiheit leider
muss man sagen welchen preis müssen die
ukraine zahlen derzeit ja aber wir
müssen zahlen sie mit allem zu
unterstützen nachdem sie fragen weil sie
wissen wie dieser krieg geführt werden
muss im augenblick sind alles
entscheiden was in richtung luftabwehr
geht deswegen ist diese zehn zu eins
frage keine entscheidende mann die frage
ist ob ihr ob wir die ukraine mit
modernen westlichen waffen ausrüsten die
auch solche alten systeme des russischen
militärs abfangen vielleicht ganz kurz
nach die ukraine haben mit dem don bass
die erfahrung gemacht dass sie einen
waffenstillstand und sogar ein abkommen
geschlossen haben und es ist nie der
frieden eingetreten obwohl die osze vor
ort war eine gemeinsame organisation von
russland und dem westen
russland hat den krieg immer weiter
köcheln lassen bis zum nächsten anlauf
und diese erfahrung haben die ukraine
deswegen schütteln sie den kopf wenn wir
ihnen sagen macht doch jetzt in waffen
viel stand sie wissen es wird die
nächste welle kommen wenn russland sich
wieder erholt hat ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich für diese sehr angeregte
diskussionen und ich bedanke mich bei
ihnen sehr herzlich fürs zuschauen dass
wir unsere sendung forum demokratie
es ging um demokratien und autokratien
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen tag
bei phoenix
[Musik]